Welcome to LWIAY!
LWIAY- Ah, oh what is this?
Oh my god!
[🎵🎵 Sponsor Jingle 🎵🎵]
[🎵] Oh!
Oh! [🎵]
80 million club merch jacket! [🎵]
Oaawh (?) [🎵]
I like dat. [🎵]
MMMMM [🎵]
MMMMMMMMMM [🎵]
That's what I'm talking about! [🎵]
Eighty Million Subscribers Gawddamnit!
I bet you L-Series doesn't have 80-mill subscribers! [🎵]
[Wow sound effect + 🎵]
Well I bet L-series doesn't have an 80 million subscriber-
merch jacket!
[WOW] That's right everybody! [🎵]
[Swede Shakes?]
Only if you have eighty million subscribers you get to wear this.
..or if you buy it [🎵 c; ]
Link in the description! [🎵]
Also this video is sponsored by G-Fuel!
[WOW! + 🎵]
[🎵 LWIAY THEME SONG]
👏 This 👏 Changes 👏 Everything 👏!
Sixty thousand upvotes. GawdDamn!
The Subreddit is now at 1.1 Jesus Christ!
When Felix realizes that PewNews has more viewers than Vöx..
which makes PewNews a mainstream meeDIAAAH
[Big Brain noises] AAAH
I mean, I already knew this.
This is why they're so gawddamn salty.
And may I say, Pewnews is the most respected...
news source out there. AND I can actually say that..
because that's my opinion WHICH I'm allowed to have!
Oh God it's my parents.
(He reads the meme... I'm being a lazy caption-er)
Well you can FORGET ABOUT IT.
Next👏Meme👏
"We're Sinking Bois"
Oh God. This is gonna be a sad episode isn't it?
[Clip is playing SAD Bish Lasagna]
A sad episode of LWIAY..
Oh god it is sad. :c
[Mr. Beast playing SAD B.Lasagna]
Is that..?
[Laughing] is that a sad version of B. Lasagna?
NooOOh! Ah, it's over. We're so close..
Guys Please!
(Not sure what he says here... uhm... :C )
[Laughs off-screen]
Oooh it's almost over!
[Felix Weeping/Groaning]
Alexa this is so sad..
It is so sad!
Ya know...
I pretty much will take the help from anyone at this pöint.
I mean, I got le help from Logan Paul.
I think it's safe to say that I'm pretty desperate.
And I wanna be fully clear - I have no other plans, okay!?
I'm all outta trap cards at this point - I got NOTHING.
T-Series is around the corner and I got nothing!
[ECHO]           DO              SÖMETHING!!!!
You already did something? Well I DON'T KNOW THEN!
We have to get to [swede mode] hundred million
so I can sell the hundred million merch!
C'mon what're you doing?!
(reads top half of meme)
That's something!
(Reads bottom of meme)
[It's Real Big Brain Hours] (Finishes reading meme)
You know it's a joke, but it's fully.. (?)
It's a great idea! Youtube-wise, ya know?
Today history has been made!
A hundred  thousand! Daym.
Okay that's pretty cool.
I guess I have to make another song.
A million, and it's already at 1.1. Goddaym!
This subreddit mån
I'm so glad I picked such a 'great' name for it..
Pewdiepie Submission... What a great name!
[Deep Gamer accent] So guys, we did it.
We beat! YouTube! Gaming!
That's right, I'M the NUMBER ONE GAMER!
I am the ....
the biggest gamer in the whole world.
Now pewdiepie is the supreme gamer.
All hail Supreme Gamer Pewdiepie Felix Kjellberg
(Reads Fanart Meme) making it to-
No! Stop it BRAD! STOP IT!
(Reads meme)
Well it's smelling me.
I sure as heck ain't sure if it smells on you. (?)
Okay?
Once L-Series takes over and they send all of us..
to Gulag, don't come complaining to me going like..
"Oh! I wish I said subscribe to Pewdiepie! -
Now I am a slave and have to do all this stuff I don't like."
Don't do that! Don't pull that SHH on me afterwards.
"Oh I'm sorry Pewdiepie"
"Oh I'm sorry I never said subscribe to PewDiePie."
Alright. It's 👏now or 👏never.
Do your part!
I've seen this! [Laughing]
Gawd Dyam! Level 50 mafia boss!
I like how you draw hair on my leg, I really appreciate that. Thank you.
Very Nice.
I cannot confirm if imZukich is a [REDACTED] or not,
but, uh .. it's a very nice fanart to say the least.
"Who are your favorite animators on Youtube?"
[Reading reply] "Hard to say, your algorithm destroyed most of them."
Ooof.
''What? didn't you see all the animators in YT Rewind?''
''They're all in YT Rewind! Hey look guys! There's animators!!''
Just a normal day in the Sub. Pewdiepie is currently-
Oh God. The end IS near.
The end is near. AH Goddaymit!!
Uuh..Okay guys.
[Motivational_pewds.wav] You guys are talking like it's already over!
It's not over yet!
We're far from over. We have a lot of fighting power left!
[Silence]
Bald brad and redhead pewds.
Nice, that's a nice shirt though.
(reads meme)
Well drinking yourself as G-Fuel, that's way different.
Don't make me laugh. Ah!
(reads height meme)
[Big ol laughter]
Seems accurate!
because everyone is saying that...
..me and mark is the same height which is just ridiculous
One seventy-nine! That's ridiculous!
How tall is pewdiepie...
I'm one eighty! I'm WAY taller!
This makes no sense..
How tall is Jacksepticeye...
Ya right! YA RIGHT!!
Who's making this up?!
How tall.. tall is uh.. brad?
Awh, what the heck?!
BRAD! Well, Brad is actually taller than me..
so now I'm confused.
Meme 👏 Review 👏 .. Yeah it's coming, definatly.
(reads title) WHAT that's sick!
That's really dope.
[Laughs] What, is this real?
(reads tweets)
(continues to read tweets)*Automatically*
(still reading tweet)
"Uses a bunch of signals" What the heck?
(reads the final tweet)
[Laugh.jpeg]     [echo.wav]
Why am I laughing? It's just sad [Laughs anyways]
Ay, wow, okay so.. [reading title] "Me (left) PDP (Right)..."
Thank you for clarifying that. I had no idea
I was like Whoa, "which one is it?"
(keeps reading title)
Well, you did get, AN EPIC BROFIST
[WOW.wav]
How tall were you back then?
What is this? Everyone's tryin to figure out my height?
There's no way Felix is 5'11
DUDE you doN'T KNOW THAT. D:<
(reads meme)
Ya should I be concerned?
What is wrong with you guys?
Do you not have any more interesting hobbies?
[Laughs] Okay, that's good. I'll save that for later.
That goes to my cringe compilation!
(reads meme)
Okay, well, thirty-thousand subs, namaste
Thank you very much!
(reading tweet)
Yes👏  Finally👏  the trump card👏
'cause I'm all out of those.
(resumes tweet) [battle.wav]
[battle.wav intensifies]
I don't think that's how it works.
(reads title)
Jack Black, I need you more than ever.
There it is!
👏There it- [Laugh.wav] 👏
It's a big difference!
There has to be a big difference!
(reads title)
-on MEME REVIEW!
[Laugh_Gasp.wav]
That's so sweet! He looks so happy!
oh my gAAAAAAAWD!
What is with all the crossovers?!
It's too early for tears.. [sincere.wav]
Stöp crying!
[sincere .wav intensifies?] Stop crying..
and start subscribing!
Stop👏Crying👏Start👏Subscribing!
[chant;loading] Stop👏Crying👏Start👏Subscribing!
Chant with me!
Chunga Chunga Chunga-
Okay.
If he was trolling with the codes I'd least like..
I-I would at least respect that, ya know?
If someone intentionally did a shht apology and just..
added a bunch of amazon gift codes as a meme, then
ya I could respect that.. but [laugh.wav]
(reads meme)
I am SO proud of this community guys! Thank you.
Oh good... (reads meme)
(reading meme)
Oh boy.
Oh. My. God. [BIG_laugh.WAV]
[big_wheeze.WAV]
Get fricked Sasuke!
Oh that's amazing!
(reads meme... that's all he does on this channel...)
I think I'm like... 5 or 6 football fields.
[Brad secret ... quick maths ... pewds=5ft?]
(reads title)
Okay... [Brad.WAV]
(Pewds reads the challenge)
I've never heard about this..
[Launches STRAIGHT into pronouncing this ... "word"]
[Starts out strong, but he loses it in the second quarter]
[regains some speed]
[returns to maximum Swede Speed. An "OKAY" finish.]
Yes! Of course!
[He goes in for another round.]
[Doesn't prove much easier...]
[battle.wav]     [Flawless pronunciation, I assume]
👏DAYM!
Whooooo!
(Reads meme/text) [kawaii.wav]
*pulls out sans.wav*
See? There you go.
Holy.. Daym... That is actually sick!
(reads title)
Well I saw it now! Unless BRAD cuts it out..
and he's a A-[Brad.wav]-hole.
but if he does, no-one will know about it.
Uhh, there's fifteen hidden references...
Daym. That's sick.
Knee!
Three Ninety-Nine! - Ugandan Knuckles!
I didn't see that, that's so cool!
Okay that's sick. Thank you very much!
This was made by Goddasaurus.
(reads title)
No! Stop! *Attacks desk* IT AIN'T OVER!!!!
[sad.wav] (Growling?) IT AIN'T OVER GAWD-D
(reads title) [yelling in Swedish ... help?]
I'm not seeing enough movement guys!
[crying] PLeeeheeheeease!
[Screeeeeeeee.wav]
(reads YT twitter BS)
(reading savage comment)
[judgmental silence]
[Will_Smith.WAV] Yaaaaa
Yaaaa (x2)
(reading meme......)
[another laugh.wav]
Oh that's great....
(reading title)
I was slouching! Okay?
There's a difference when you sit "like this" and sit "like this"
[Brad.wav]
That's all I got.
Thank you guys for watching this episode of "LWIAY"
Youtube's favorite show! Hope you guys enjoyed,
smash like if you did. Remember to buy the headphones,
the hat, the uh-shirt, the G-Fuel, uh the Chair -
Check out the game!
Annnd uh, that's it! That's it. That's all ya gotta do
That's all I'm asking for. What else coul-
Jesus Christ guys.....
[sad.jpeg] I'm just a struggling YouTuber ... please
[brad.wav]
[ an ad for Youtuber Simulator. Go download it it's free. ]